E aí
[Música]
é
a boa tarde
o
Ivan di
spinaci name
and I love you
I want now playing I love you
um dos André em
maneira ficou um I can Forget
All Your Love
for You
o
site nave
[Música]
e não a pensou
a neve mim durante
e Spinner raro
my my my life
e antes lei da pauta
início
[Música]
mamão
mais
babá bomba bomba bomba
[Música]
babão daí é
Oi e eu a
jantar
de site
cansa manda-me o Face dos filmes mal
[Música]
ou não
forever Liss
se alguém não não não e não
avisou nada
mentindo retrátil
[Música]
o
Spinner Orange estive
[Música]
na babá mais
just take Little
e duas Blood Blood Blood
I love to be like you
[Música]
o PIS
Ah tá obrigado
[Aplausos]
E aí é o nome Mr Aline
eu vim aqui de uma mala aqui que
pertence Alcobaça chamada prisões e
pronto e foi convidado para para vir
aqui o outro é sexy tocar umas músicas
e entretanto em conversa hoje falará
está te ver que ser falar dizer assim
mas histórias e deram uma ideia que eu
podia falar aqui um bocado não muito
porque não tenho muito tempo
mas falar sobre aquilo lá singularidades
mas eu não tenho nada não tenho muita
vida de sobre singularidades entretanto
falaram é para mas os teus instrumentos
que tu usas de alguma forma são
singulares e
pronto e a fazer aqui uma breve
introdução
dos instrumentos que eles aqui nos pés a
o e de como eles surgiram na altura
comecei a tem algumas músicas na cabeça
comecei a gravar em casa e que de alguma
maneira
as músicas que eu gravava em casa tinham
para além de guitarra tinha um baterias
e baixos e sintetizadores e
quando decidir tocar ao vivo foi uma
coisa assim que ela a pessoa importante
em um concerto e tinha que só fará um
concerto ao vivo não tinha forma de não
tinha banda para tocar com esses
instrumentos todos e tive que arranjar
assim procurar em casa o que é que tinha
para para poder Safari e um deles Era
este instrumento basicamente é um são
dois ovinhos chamam-se o Segue
em que a juntos fita-cola peguei não
elástico tinha da minha mãe do cabelo ah
porque na verdade eu estivesse a tocar
guitarra não tinha espaço para tocar os
outros instrumentos que as mãos e tive
que arranjar neste caso os outros
membros inferiores que são os pés e com
elástico sempre aconselha por aqui Olá
o e conseguia fazer este som
eu já fiz depois arranjei outra coisa
que encontrei na internet que nem sabia
que existia quer um chamada fu tamborim
é uma pandeireta de fé que podia colocar
no outro
e
pronto assim já tinha meio a banda feita
que era eu a tocar na guitarra com as
mãos e com os pés já tinha entretanto
havia outras coisas que os
sintetizadores e coisas que eu gostava
de pelo menos tocar ao vivo mas que não
conseguia porque não tinha instrumentos
todos e e arranjei
outro instrumento que teu caso é o
instrumento qualquer pessoa sabe tocar
[Música]
qualquer coisa e pronta pai isto serve
de guitarra de sintetizador de muitos
instrumentos e pronto vou buscar uma
música de do meu primeiro disco
é a que se chama hein mãe mãe e que
pronto e que surgiu
a surgir um bocado por falta desses
instrumentos e vivenciais depois me
levaram achar que este caso poderá ser
fixo para para introduzir o
E aí
[Música]
e então me mandou Olha aí ela vai queima
então
quando é cão de Chico
Harry Finger
Snap referes to
play
[Música]
its
normal aqui ó
[Música]
o
travesti disse mexer ae
[Música]
aulas em Chamas not my son
e parece tenso na
mais andamos
milhão de
nada se presta ao não e nada
[Música]
tá na hora de tu é
Que horas vai ser o ensaio allow her
Close I am saying that feeling
[Música]
everything is not Clear whether it is to
be
friends now just playing on
a irmã
Marta the map of my
pizza
bray
hits funky Brown
take time
E aí
[Música]
A
realist Sítio sunshine
[Música]
alguns estamos na primeira e
as pedras Sweet
mamãe
beijão sei que me virar não sei que me
deu
[Música]
essa prisão
ou não e na dela é
[Música]
é
feriado e
E aí
e pronto outro dos instrumentos que dá
para tocar sem ser com as mãos é uma
harmônica
bom graças a este incrível
dispositivo que nos permite ter
harmônica à frente da boca
a qualquer momento
eu te conheço como fazer outra música
que a última que vou tocar e
foi um prazer estar aqui e até já
[Música]
E aí
o
réu Man what's the mine inscrição
Oi Vani
tripp-lite
Rita
pela
anda Val
é que fala Disc in Lines 99
bom então é TP
largaram mais
e me fala de esquina mais nada tchau
a Rita única fila de piada uau
se te falta que fez itens aqui ó
E ai
cantam não não não é
ah ah não
usa não
ensinarei James mais
o its allies in
dry and we all know all I Break this
heart Should I Stay Should I
E aí
[Música]
e
também Hot Mini arte som
[Música]
a
Sharp lycra roll-on
bom
então e te pila teve andam Paulo
a esf penhora sunshine notas para
[Aplausos]
não não não
sim sim
não
não não
hum
[Música]
it's all
strains and
now are they
Should I
E aí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
E aí
[Música]
e obrigado fiquem bem
E aí
G1